[Musique]
bonjour à tous et à toutes l'invité de
saint roch a dit ce matin chez glénat
renard parlons porte parole de la france
a soumises de jean luc mélenchon bonjour
thierry renard toujours un seul ivry
bons journaux martinique en début de
semaine le maire de fort de france a
participé à une conférence nationale
pour la sécurité autres maires pour
didier laguerre le phénomène de gangs
nous guette les délinquants sont de plus
en plus dures dangereux et violents car
en passe de trafic d'herbe à un trafic
de cocaïne et jean luc mélenchon lui
veut supprimer la brigade
anticriminalité la bac
oui tout à fait alors c'est bien qu'on
en fasse ce constat parce que c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui que ça dure que la
situation en pillant et il ya deux
manières de résoudre des problèmes soit
on ne fait de la répression à tout va
soit on essaie de prendre le mal à la
racine dans le programme de la france
est soumise
on veut supprimer les bacs pour les
remplacer par des polices de proximité
site ça ne sonne pas le même rôle il
s'agira du tout le même rêve c'est pas
la même fonction c'est à dire que les
2000 de police peuvent cohabiter mais
justement c'est à dire que avant de
faire de la répression il faut d'abord
amener les jeunes
est ce que ce n'est pas animé une
connaissance de la réalité du terrain
méconnaissance de la délinquance la
méconnaissance vient du fait que
aujourd'hui les jeunes sont livrés à eux
mêmes nous dans le programme de la
france est soumise
nous voulons remettre le pied à l'étrier
aux jeunes c'est à dire que ceux qui
sont dans la rue on propose par exemple
de l'eau ne leur met un service citoyen
de neuf mois sans casernement ça leur
permettra d'apprendre un métier de
pouvoir avoir une structure parce que
vous savez l'armée c'est une structure
où vous obéissez la bague fonctionne
surtout la nuit
oui et la nuit comment vous faites pour
lutter contre la délinquance
mais monsieur livory passe
si la politisation quelqu'un si
quelqu'un est occupé la journée travail
la journée à une fonction une activité
la journée la nuit il dort
ce n'est pas de l'angélisme non ce n'est
pas de l'angélisme vous écoutez est ce
que vous pourriez vous passez vos nuits
a traîné dans les rues
si vous devez le matin vous trouvez au
travail vous ne pouvez pas donc il faut
occuper ces jeunes avec des activités
saines comment comme on le dit à la nuit
est mère de tous les vices
donc il faut arrêter de laisser ces
jeunes dans la rue livrés à eux mêmes il
faut leur donner quelque chose et ce que
nous proposons c'est par exemple que les
jeunes qui sont à l'école et qui sont
obligés de laisser par exemple l'école
pour aller travailler pour subvenir à
leurs besoins
donc même si sur tous vos inscrits dans
un cursus scolaire et qu'il n'y arrive
pas parce qu'on ne peut pas réussir à
l'école tout en travaillant que ces
jeunes là on leur donne une allocation
une allocation jeunesse pouvant
poursuivre leur trafic de drogue
rapporte plus que l'allocation comment
vous faites pour lutter contre ça
écoutez il y aura toujours une frange de
jeunes qui vont toujours vouloir essayer
de gagner de l'argent facilement
évidemment vu l'exemple qu'on leur donne
avec un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques ou de délinquants en col
blanc 1 qui se font de l'argent sur le
dos du peuple sans que la justice ne
bouge
c'est ça qui crée ce genre de situation
donc aujourd'hui nous nous disons qu'il
faut changer leur modèle parce que le
modèle que nous utilisons aujourd'hui il
n'est pas bon la répression ce n'est pas
cela la seule solution qu'il ya alors on
va avancer jean luc mélenchon veut aussi
une refondation démocratique des traités
européens
si ça ne marche pas il propose un plan b
la sortie de l'europe c'est bien cela
oui tout à fait
alexis presse le premier ministre grec
s'est quand même cassé les dents parce
qu'il voulait rené gauthier les traités
justement
oui monsieur avec 6,6 presse il avait un
emploi ils n'avaient pas de plan b
notamment
évidemment si vous arrivez avec un plan
a et qu'on vous dit non et ben voilà
c'est terminé
alors nous avons un plan a et nous avons
un plan b alors sur sur l'europe
il faut bien comprendre vos besoins
l'europe a été construite sur le fait
que les pays européens riches devaient
aider les pays européens pauvres à se
développer
c'est ça le fondement et c'est une des
bases mêmes de la france est soumise
c'est à dire que vous contribuez selon
vos moyens et vous recevez selon vos
besoins
c'est ça le fondement alors ils ont
emmené les blessés - théaux terminé sur
ce point donc aujourd'hui les deux
piliers sous sap une loi c'est la france
et l'allemagne
c'est pas la même chose avec la grèce si
la france s'en va c'est l'europe qui
marche sur une jambe ça posera un
véritable problème
donc aujourd'hui nous allons négocier
pour mettre en place la véritable europe
sociale et non cette eau de lobbies ou
des commissaires vienne et en fait ce
sont des lobbys qui impose aux états
leurs modes de fonctionnement
la france a beaucoup évolué n'est plus
ce que ce qu'elle était
si vous vous portez à une fin de non
recevoir
vous allez mettre en place le plan b la
sortie de l'europe
la sortie de l'europe qui commet la
martinique peut vivre sans l'europe
quand tout est construit ici grâce à
l'euro on parle des lycées en parle des
routes en parle du transport on parle
des hôpitaux on parle des terrains de
foot par exemple
ben vous voyez les anglais sont sortis
de l'europe
le bleu bleu breakes site vous savez que
les anglais eux ils avaient une
ristourne
ça veut dire que il contribua au pot
s'ils mettaient 100 millions 500
milliards on leur donnait leur 100
milliards tout simplement
la france contribue au pot donc mais
aujourd'hui la france donne selon ses
moyens et reçoit selon ses besoins
mais vous comprenez bien que si
aujourd'hui la france n'est plus dans
l'europe auquel fait partie des pays
c'est l'absence explosion de l'euro ça
veut dire tout simplement que juste plus
il y aura des gens qui ont de l'argent
en moins et la france soit de l'argent
en plus tout simplement comment mais
parce que la france ne va plus contribué
au oui mais pas la hauteur pas la
hauteur quand même de ce qu apporter
l'europe europe
yves illusion secteur plusieurs séries
très logique bénéficier de fonds ce
routier tout l'argent du monde où
l'argent européen
il vient d'où l'argent européen à part
des européens des européens eux mêmes
vous seriez qu'à l'argent vient de la
roumanie
certains économistes disent que c'est ce
serait une véritable catastrophe pour
l'emploi oui parce que c'est une
véritable catastrophe pour eux parce que
ça va changer leur modèle
cela ça ne va pas c'est eux qui vont
perdre de l'argent mais pour la
population la population va gagner de
l'argent vous pensez que aujourd'hui si
je fais un comparatif très simple vous
prenez n'importe quelle boisson gazeuse
à n'importe quel sodas vendus
eh bien vous comparer le prix
aujourd'hui avec le prix d'il ya vingt
ans et vous fait la différence tout de
suite alors rapidement vous jean luc
mélenchon propose également pour
l'outre-mer de nationaliser les
installations des équipements de la
sarre a créé une compagnie publique une
trame irene chargés de
l'approvisionnement dit quand
l'hydrocarbure mais aussi à terme chargé
du raffinage crois qu est ce que ça veut
dire quoi ça va changer le prix à la
pompe alors l'énergie c'est une affaire
d'état
aujourd'hui on a laissé l'énergie à des
privés vous ne pouvez pas vis en énergie
comme vous ne pouvez pas vivre sans eau
comme vous me baby 100 m imaginez-vous
qui ont accès au dossier et pour
l'instant vous psy pour la population ça
paraît un peu bizarre mais on vous taxe
l'eau deux ravissants au qu'est-ce que
ça va changer ce que ça va changer mais
le savent a chargé à la pompe ce sur
tout ce qui est évidemment que ça va
changer le prix à la pompe par quel
mécanisme
par quel mécanisme mais par le simple
fait que l'état est là pour rendre
service public et que le privé est là
pour faire de binic services publics
départ obligatoirement rentable mais un
service public n'a pas à être rentable
un service public est là pour rendre
service ce n'est pas là pour faire de
l'argent qu'on
faites de l'argent c'est qu'on vous êtes
un privé et c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui même pôle de transport
etc
nous avons des partenariats public privé
des délégations de service public et les
dégâts les délégations de service public
c'est un moyen pour le privé de prendre
l'argent du public points jerry renard
je vous remercie je rappelle que vous
êtes le porte parole de la france à
soubise de jean luc mélenchon vous merci
beaucoup
on n'a pas eu le temps de parler de
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses
malheureuses moins bonne journée à tous